les violences faites aux femmes se
manifeste dans l'intimité
elle se manifeste à l'écart des regards
et la douleur qu'elle provoque est
souvent difficile à partager parce que
la honte réduit au silence elle acheté
de cette violence à huit clos ne doit
pas nous tenir à distance au contraire
il faut redoubler d'efforts pour donner
à cette le tout la porte et qu'elle
mérite
en en faisant l'objet d'une véritable
prise de conscience collectif l'état
c'est sa mission doit veiller à ce que
les plus faibles soient protégés par la
loi et que leurs droits fondamentaux à
commencer par le droit à l'intégrité
physique soit respecté ses droits nous
avons à les faire respecter au delà des
portes fermées par delà la chape de
silence qui entoure des actes de
violence ordinaire soigneusement
confinés par delà le déni qui masque une
souffrance domestique ou professionnelle
continue
cette année la journée internationale
pour l'élimination de la violence à
l'égard des femmes revêt une dimension
particulière
d'abord parce que c'est exactement il ya
dix ans les nations unies dédiée ce 25
novembre un combat injustement méconnu
est consacré la nécessité de lui donner
une visibilité monde
aujourd'hui ça fait dix ans que la
résolution était adoptée disant que le
combat s'organise et que les consciences
s'ouvre progressivement très
progressivement sa réalité
si cela est possible c'est d'abord grâce
à l'action courageuse de femme engagée
qui prennent des risques et qui prêtent
leurs voix à celles qui ne le peuvent
pas ou qui ne logent pas pour débusquer
et combattre cette violence nous avons
encore beaucoup beaucoup de progrès à
faire
l'année dernière dans notre pays 157
femmes ont perdu la vie sous les coups
de leur conjoint en france une femme
décède tous les deux jours et demi sous
ce type de violence un meurtre sur cinq
est commis par un homme qui tourne sa
violence contre sa campagne où son ex
compris cette réalité dévastatrice est
indifférente aux catégories sociales
indifférente aux âges ou à la géographie
elle s'exerce au quotidien dans toutes
les classes sociales et sur l'ensemble
de notre territoire
elle se noue dans le secret des foyers
et sur les lieux de travail
partout elle nous met en face d'un des
paradoxes les plus incompréhensibles et
les plus avilissant de la nature humaine
quelle que soit sa manifestation cette
brutalité n'est ni tolérable ni légitime
le gouvernement a fait de la lutte
contre toutes les formes de violence une
priorité
qu'ils s'agissent des agressions
sexuelles des violences psychologiques
des mutilations sexuelles des violences
physiques ou des mariages forcés
ce matin nadine morano a présenté en
conseil des ministres les mesures
destinées à donner à donner une nouvelle
impulsion à cette à la protection de la
femme
la semaine dernière elle était en
espagne pour étudier et nouveaux moyens
expérimenté dans ce pays
basé sur un dispositif de surveillance
électronique du conjoint violent parce
que dans ce domaine il faut examiner
toutes les pistes tout à l'heure xavier
darcos réunira la commission nationale
de lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
et avant-hier à bobigny michèle alliot
marie a rappelé que le combat contre les
violences conjugales
elle est indissociable des valeurs de
notre société démocratique
sur le plan judiciaire je crois qu'on
peut faire un constat positif
la problématique spécifique des
violences conjugales a été prise en
compte par l'ensemble des cours d'appel
sur le territoire national elle
s'attache à mettre en place des
dispositifs de réponses pénales
systématiques envers les auteurs et de
prise en charge des victimes des
violences bien sûr ces dispositifs sont
encore perfectibles et les juridictions
d'ailleurs s'attacha à toujours mieux
adapter les réponses à ce contentieux
particulier il est en outre
indispensable que ces réponses soit
cohérente sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
parce que si la délinquance n'est pas
identique et si le réseau associatif
diffèrent en fonction des moyens de
chaque département et des problématiques
locales
il faut pas que les disparités entre les
politiques pénales ajoute une forme
d'injustice à une autre
les parlementaires se sont également
saisis du sujet je veux d'abord citer
les travaux menés par les délégation aux
droits des femmes des deux assemblées
ces dernières années je pense aussi à la
mission de l'assemblée nationale
présidée par danièle bousquet et d'un
guy geoffroy a été le rapporteur
ces travaux ont été très largement
saluée
il se prolonge aujourd'hui même par le
dépôt d'une proposition de loi qui
reprend les principales propositions de
la mission je veux dire que le
gouvernement est totalement ouvert à
cette proposition de loi qui recouvre
d'ailleurs largement les préoccupations
que nous avons exprimé
l'année dernière j'avais souhaité
consacrer l'année 2009 à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes en
l'élevant au rang de campagne d'intérêt
général en attribuant ce premier label
j'avais invité les associations à
s'organiser encore davantage qu'un pour
que la lutte contre les violences
puissent être la prochaine grande cause
nationale en 2010 et bien je vous
annonce aujourd'hui la grande cause
nationale de 2010 ce sera bien la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et l'attribution de ce label c'est
d'abord la reconnaissance de
l'importance que le gouvernement accorde
à cette cause et c'est aussi la
reconnaissance du travail effectué par
vos associations sans votre action de
terrain la mobilisation des services de
l'état ne pourrait pas porter ses fruits
cette reconnaissance officielle je pense
qu'elle va offrir au combat des
associations une visibilité accrue et un
accès qui est essentiel aux médias pour
poursuivre ce qui est d'abord une oeuvre
de sensibilisation
depuis 2008 nous avons engagé un
deuxième plan d'action triennal ciblée
sur les violences faites aux femmes
la stratégie que nous avons choisie a
permis des avancées sur trois fronts
d'abord en matière de prise en charge
des victimes
j'ai souhaité que soit créé un véritable
parcours d'orientation pour les femmes
victimes de violences à côté du rôle
prépondérant joué par les associations
nous avons voulu constituer un réseau de
référents locaux pour les femmes
victimes se référant est un
interlocuteur unique de proximité
depuis un an ils se sont largement
développées et c'est un progrès mais il
nous faut aller plus loin il faut que
nous arrivions à un maillage beaucoup
plus pertinent du territoire en lien
avec les associations
parallèlement nous avons renforcé les
moyens de la plateforme d'écouté
téléphonique du 39 19
ils permettent désormais de répondre à
près de 80 mille appels par an enfin
nous avons continué nos efforts pour
améliorer l'accueil l'hébergement des
femmes en détresse en particulier dans
les centres d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale
nous avons désormais un parc de près de
39 milles places qui permettent aux
femmes victimes de violence dans la
plupart des cas d'avoir la possibilité
de s'y mettre à l'abri de façon
immédiate
parfois même dans des structures pas
toujours qui sont spécialement dédiés à
cet effet pour répondre deuxième
impératif qui est la prise en charge des
auteurs de violences nous avons élaboré
en lien avec les acteurs du terrain et
l'ensemble des ministères concernés une
charte destinée aux structures de prise
en charge et de suivi des auteurs de
violences en 2006 2007 nous avions
recensé une soixantaine de structures de
ce type en signant cette charte nous
souhaitons que toutes les structures
intervenant auprès des auteurs de
violences au sein du couple s'engage à
respecter un certain nombre de grands
principes fédérateur prendre en compte
les auteurs de violences c'est d'une
certaine façon une approche novatrice
dans notre lutte façon toute naturelle
dès le départ c'est vers les victimes
que cette approche s'est structurée mais
les violences de nous parlons ont ceci
de particulier qu'elles concernent des
victimes et des auteurs qui sont ou qui
ont été liés de façon très étroite par
des liens très intense et à partir de là
il est souvent difficile de traiter les
uns sans prendre en compte les autres
l'implication des associations dans la
prise en charge des auteurs est une
évolution notoire de la gestion du
problème nous l'intégrons désormais à
notre logique d'action d'autant plus que
cette prise en charge participent à la
lutte contre la récidive
enfin pour toucher et responsabiliser un
public aussi large que possible
il faut que les esprits changent le
rapport de michèle reiser sur l'image
des femmes dans les médias a montré
combien certains stéréotypes souvent aux
dieux ou dégradants sont encore prégnant
combien nous deux
les combattre être vigilants sur ces
sujets c'est la raison pour laquelle je
lui ai demandé de poursuivre sa mission
afin que cette fonction de vigie
continue d'être exercées sur le terrain
des préjugés qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences absolument dramatiques dans
le prolongement de la campagne 2008 nous
allons lancer une campagne de
communication sur l'image des femmes et
sur les violences verbales à partir
d'aujourd'hui un spot télévisé sur
l'importance de l'éducation
respect des genres dès le plus jeune âge
va être diffusée sur l'ensemble des
chaînes de notre pays nous allons
également cibler des publics sensibles
comme les jeunes en étant dans
l'opération menée l'an dernier avec la
brochure respect les filles diffusé à
l'ensemble des filles âgés de 18 ans
cette fois ci l'opération pas cibler les
garçons et les primo arrivants
une plaquette d'information destinée aux
bénéficiaires du contrat d'accueil et
d'intégration leur sera distribué en
on les sensibiliser aux questions
relatives à l'égalité des droits et à la
prévention des violences au sein de la
famille pense que ce volet éducatif est
absolument capital si l'on veut
efficacement relayé l'idée essentielle
que i dans ce domaine des violences il
n'existe aucune fatalité
notre action d'information ciblera
également les professionnels et
notamment ceux qui accueillent les
étrangers primo-arrivants sur les plates
formes de l'office français pour
l'immigration et l'intégration
nous diffuserons auprès de le guide de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
issus de l'immigration y accordent une
place toute particulière à la lutte
contre les mariages forcés aux
mutilations sexuelles féminines
parallèlement au plan triennal nous
avons enclenché d'autres chantiers
gouvernementaux qui ont une incidence
sur le sujet qui nous rassemble je veux
citer ici trois exemples ce que nous
avons lancé avec fadela amara sur la
dynamique espoir banlieues des points
d'accès au droit ont été mis en place
dans les quartiers sensibles
98 centre d'information sur les droits
des femmes et des familles ont été
financés via l' agence nationale pour la
cohésion sociale et l'égalité des
chances
on a mis en place quatre mille deux
cents enfants adultes relais qui
pratiquent des actions de médiation sur
les territoires de la politique de la
ville ce sont souvent des partenaires
très précieux pour favoriser l'accès aux
droits des femmes
nous avons organisé avec le ministre de
la santé roselyne bachelot le maillage
du territoire par des ateliers santé
ville qui garantissent aux femmes
victimes de violence une offre de soins
de proximité et une prise en charge
médicale et psychologique
enfin dans le cadre du plan
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance
le gouvernement s'est mobilisé pour
installer 150 intervenants sociaux dans
les commissariats de police et les
unités de gendarmerie et j'ai eu
l'occasion moi même de constater il ya
quelques jours a cure ville que sept
intervenants sociaux cet intervenant
social avait un rôle considérable dans
le déclenchement de la démarche en
matière de dénonciation des violences
faites aux femmes
alors aujourd'hui il s'agit de donner au
plan triennal 2008 2010 avec vous une
nouvelle impulsion à bord nous voulons
mieux protéger les femmes victimes de
violence en renforçant le cadre
juridique
en matière civile il faut d'abord
répondre à l'urgence des situations en
protégeant les femmes en danger afin
qu'elles bénéficient ce sans délai de
mesures de protection
un régime juridique de référé-protection
va être créé et qui interviendra donc en
amont du dépôt de plainte ou
indépendamment du dépôt de pâtes
ensuite il s'agit d'éloigner le conjoint
violent
pour cela nous allons étendre la
procédure d'éviction de l'auteur de
violences prévues par le code civil
actuellement applicables aux conjoints
mariés
elle sera désormais applicable aux
personnes liées par un pacte civil de
solidarité et aux concubins
ça mettra un terme à des inégalités
absurde dans la protection accordée aux
victimes
en matière pénale le délit de violences
psychologiques au sein du couple va être
consacré par le législateur
c'est une avancée considérable parce que
la création de ce délit va permettre de
prendre en compte les situations les
plus sournoises ces situations qui ne
laissent pas de traces à l'oeil nu mais
qui mutilent l'être intérieur des
victimes
l'ensemble de ces modifications sera
introduit dans notre droit avant l'été
2010 si toutefois les parlementaires
travaillent à un rythme suffisant
les associations fournissent une
remontée d'informations importantes sur
la question des mariages forcés
il faut que le gouvernement s'en
saisissent à son tour et à ce sujet la
mission parlementaire dont ou dit
geoffroy a été le rapporteur a fait une
proposition de création d'un nouveau
délit
le gouvernement est prêt à examiner les
façons d'assumer un meilleur encadrement
pénale du mariage forcé notre deuxième
axe d'action portera sur la prévention
de la récidive
au delà des dispositifs existants il
faut réfléchir à des nouvelles
structures sur la base de l'exemple
espagnol nous allons lancer
l'expérimentation d'un dispositif de
surveillance électronique pour contrôler
l'effectivité de la mesure d'éloignement
du conjoint violent dès le début de
l'année 2010
elle sera testée comme une alternative
aux poursuites ou comme une modalité
d'exercice de la peine dans le cadre d'
obligations de la peine d'emprisonnement
avec sursis et mise à l'épreuve ou de
suivi socio judiciaire
cette initiative sera inscrite dans la
loi nous allons aussi faire des efforts
particuliers pour améliorer le repérage
et la prise en charge des victimes
nous prévoyons d'offrir systématiquement
à tous les professionnels susceptibles
d'avoir à traiter des situations de
violence au sein du couple sommes dans
le domaine de la protection de l'enfance
une formation spécifique
la formation initiale des professionnels
de santé les médecins les infirmiers les
sages femmes qui intègre déjà les
mutilations sexuelles féminines inclura
aussi à l'avenir la gestion des victimes
de violences intrafamiliales
le ministère chargé de l'intégration
soutient également l'offre de formations
destinées aux acteurs de terrain et aux
professionnels de la plateforme des
coudes du 39 19
autour de la problématique des mariages
forcés et des mutilations sexuelles et
en 2010 je lui ai demandé de les
développer encore dernier chantier
nous devons nous donner les moyens de
mieux mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène des
violences faites aux femmes
dès 2010 nous allons lui consacrer une
nouvelle enquête en nous basant sur les
travaux engagés par l'institut national
d'études démographiques et nous allons
nous concentrer en particulier sur le
phénomène des mariages forcés afin de
mieux les combats voilà cette année
mesdames et messieurs l'organisation des
nations unies a décidé de placer la
commémoration du 10e anniversaire de
cette journée internationale sous le
triple signe de l'engagement de l'action
et de l'exigence
si les prises de conscience se
multiplient il nous revient encore et
encore d'élever la voix et d'agir parce
que partout dans le monde des femmes
continuent à être exploité à être battu
à être violée à être tué une femme sur
deux est victime d'actes de violence de
la part de son compagnon et une sur cinq
dans le monde est victime ou menacés
d'agressions sexuelles
en plus des souffrances qu'elles
engendrent ces violations des droits
fondamentaux perpétrés contre les femmes
compromettent leur insertion dans la vie
sociale dans la vie économique et dans
la vie politique et par là-même
compromettent le développement et la
sécurité de toute la société qui les
tolère si la violence envers les femmes
se décline sous de multiples formes est
là partout les mêmes effets et elle est
fatal au principe d'égalité des hommes
et des femmes et elle est fatale en
réalité à la dignité de l'humanité nous
devons pour que cette violation des
droits de l'homme prenne fin il a
dénoncé avec le plus en plus de force et
publiquement
nous devons empêcher qu'elles se
déroulent impunément à l'abri des
regards
nous devons la sortir du silence dans
laquelle elle se retranche protégé par
la honte qui souvent accable des
victimes
injustement culpabilisés par des faits
qui en réalité déshonneur leurs auteurs
nous devons déclencher une prise de
conscience telle que chacun dans la
société se sente investi d'une
responsabilité dans un domaine qui a été
beaucoup trop longtemps cantonnée à la
sphère privée
la vérité c'est qu'en la matière il n'ya
pas de sphère privée le combat contre la
violence faite aux femmes c'est la
sphère de pouce le combat contre la
violence faite aux familles nous
commandent d'agir partout où la dignité
la morale et la loi l'exigent et je veux
vous remercier vous les responsables des
associations la fois pour avoir été les
premiers ou les premières à tirer le
signal d'alarmé pour conduire sur le
terrain ce combat si difficile contre
l'indifférence l'habitude
les traditions qui font qu'on refuse de
voir les choses et quand on les observe
dans les pays plus éloignés nous
apparaissent comme intolérable et
totalement contraire à l'image que nous
faisons de notre société et de
l'humanité vous remercie
vous venez de suivre en direct le
discours de françois fillon sur les
violences